and then you guys can beat them head up
i mean then you win the division with
all that you guys you guys you you
purple people eater you yes you're a
vikings fan wear it as a badge of honor
your defense is a little scary you see
it on your sidelines that was a huge
blow to your team halfway through the
third quarter he fumbles the ball yeah i
don't trust your corners but i don't
think you're totally out the division
race if there's a weakness to your team
it is the depth of your defensive run
seven and for you guys mike i mean you
know the one thing and i'm saying stop
it i'm saying you guys are in vikings
okay
that was awesome
[Music]
that was all from the same conversation
the same show at some point during the
uh 2019 football season my goodness uh
sounds like that was like after the
bears game you know early in the year
where we're like what the hell is going
on what's up with the vikings what's up
with kirk cousins you're always a little
dr doomish it's always a little gloomy
when it comes to you talking the vikings
i can't wait for this right now well
no no look look i've got the vikings at
number 13 in the pft preseason power
rankings ahead of the defending nfc
north champion green bay packers by one
spot the packers went to the nfc
championship game where they were
trounced by the 49ers the vikings took
their whipping from the 49ers a week
earlier
but look as of right now i and chris
this is something we talked about when
mike zimmer was getting his contract
extension i feel like the packers
consciously took a step back
in the hopes of eventually taking
multiple steps forward yeah i feel like
the vikings have just decided to tread
water because i feel like at a certain
level
the vikings are content
to contend
but
there's no indication to think that
they're going to show up and they're
going to be this dominant presence that
goes wire to wire
one seed finishes the job returns at the
super bowl for the first time in 44
years haven't been back they were there
four times between number four and
number
11. and they haven't been back since
then
and i just feel like they're in that
perpetual
fringe
of
good enough
but not great enough yeah so 13 is
fitting right maybe they win the
division but do you really see this team
and we'll get into the
nooks and crannies
do you really see this team
contending with the best teams that the
conference is going to have to offer in
2020 because i don't no i don't either
you know mike i you know again i've been
liking your rankings here
when i saw vikings at 13 it was one of
the teams that jumped out to me to where
i went oh i don't know about 13
that might be a little high for them
this year you know what what are the you
know you you explained it well it's not
like a rebuild but it's kind of like a
retool uh retooling on the fly here but
a lot of turnover on this roster this
last year and yeah it's not you know
yeah maybe it you know ends up being a
good thing a year or two down the road
but i'm not so sure i sit here and
believe that it's going to be a good
thing here in 2020 that like you said i
don't think they've improved their
football team you know again defensive
line let's just start there the defense
is you got a pretty damn good defense
it's i i can't see it being as good as
last year i i don't you know everson
griffin not there linville joseph's not
there you signed michael pierce from
baltimore and free agency he opted out
because of the code 19. right so xavier
rhodes gone trey wayne's gone you're
gonna have some new pieces at corner you
know i know you got the linebackers and
safeties they're special you know but
then the offense you know again there's
questions there too yeah stefan diggs
second biggest playmaker on that team
last year other than dalvin cook you
know the offensive line yeah it's been
it's better it's still a work in
progress so i you know i would sit here
really and i would go most divisions in
football i go man the vikings got no
chance of winning that division the nfc
north uh though is a different story i
don't know if there is that team there
so yeah can they stay competitive there
and do all that yes but i don't think
they're gonna be as good as what we've
seen the last few years there in
minnesota i don't see this as being a
playoff team in my eyes
let me start with the defense yeah and
look i i
they were hoping to get everson griffin
back everson griffin had on opt-out
clause in his contract which was smart
because the vikings would have
eventually squeezed him to take less and
maybe cut him after the money wasn't
there now the problem is because of the
pandemic he wasn't able to go out and
get a big deal early in free agency but
he was able to go wherever he wanted to
go he chose dallas for a one-year deal
worth up to 6 million the vikings
clearly weren't in that conversation or
they would have had a shot to bring him
back because that's where he's been for
his entire 10-year career before now
he's a big loss i think from a
leadership standpoint yeah and you know
he's good at getting around the
quarterback and he's good at opening
things up for everyone else trey waynes
and xavier rhodes
dollar for dollar i don't view that as a
significant loss because mike zimmer is
very good at coaching up young defensive
backs they'll have guys who can come out
and get it done they're going to need
guys who can come out and get it done
yeah
yeah but but the bigger issue with the
defense i think is
the scheme
it's almost like the concerns you have
with the seattle defense sure like it's
a scheme and the code can be cracked and
i know of coaches who very easily can
crack that code they know they know guys
are always in the same spot they always
do the same things they always react the
same way so you can fool them
or take advantage of the holes that are
there because ultimately you only have
that's the thing there's always 11
pieces on the defense yeah and if you're
going to go one way then something's
going to be open and that's why when we
talk about the seattle defense you know
and rodney harrison said last week it's
better to have the ability to confuse
pre-snaps so you don't know where those
11 guys are going to be the viking
scheme's gotten a little predictable and
that's one of the reasons mike zimmer
brought in dom capers this year yes
who's a 3-4 guy maybe we're going to see
some mixed elements here where there's
more guessing that needs to be done now
good luck getting all that installed
yeah right and it's time you know a
season without an offseason program but
i think the defense chris needs that
that that refresh not a rebuild not a
reload just to refresh and zimmer's good
enough to come up with some new concepts
but i think he's at a point in his
career where he realizes his defense has
taken him as far as it's going to take
him and it's never going to take him
into the super bowl yeah out something
without some some goosing of the scheme
to make it a little more unpredictable
and make it a little bit harder to
schema agreed mike there's no doubt i
mean there's some similarities to that
seattle scheme and mike zimmer scheme
and listen mike zimmer he's one of the
best defensive coaches of our time i
mean he really is and i don't want to
discredit them that way but you're right
there is some predictability with the
scheme and what they're how they're
going to play and i really i you know
like
standing ovation really for bringing the
guy like in like dom capers honestly i
think mike zimmer realized that a little
last year where he well obviously he did
i mean you know he's self-scattered
thyself he's a smart guy you know and i
saw him do a few different things
towards the end of the year and even in
the playoff game where they beat the
saints where i went ooh
zimmer doesn't usually quite play like
this or this coverage in this type of
situation to where it made me think like
wait he's probably a little bit like man
sean payton's got a hold of my stuff and
i got to be more multiple so it's not
going to take a lot it won't just a few
little wrinkles here and there from a
guy like don capers certainly can give
them more of a schematical advantage but
you know i i guess you know the big
thing is
you know i just don't know i don't see
anything on the vikings right now to
where i go
you know this really excites me yeah i
know gary kubiak's the oc and he knows
how to run the football but the passing
game is less than in my eyes it's very
simple it's very predictable that way so
if you're not dominating the run game
you know i don't know if the rest of the
offense always works which scares me and
you talked about that a lot last year
kirk cousins was a different guy because
when they ran the ball the play actions
the bootleg certainly
became open and then when it became a
game where they couldn't run the ball
and they have to drop back pass i don't
think their offense is extensive enough
to capitalize on stuff like that so you
know they're one of these weird teams
that you know i look at and go i think
they'll be competitive
they'll be a pain in the butt for a lot
of teams in football but as you say i
don't think they're any threat of going
deep into the playoffs or going to a
super bowl i think they're a borderline
borderline playoff contender this year
that's about as about where i see it
chris the vikings are the equivalent of
that high school team and it seems like
there are high school teams like this
throughout the country who are run only
they have this running scheme and we're
going to run the ball run the ball run
the ball and it's going to serve them
well because they do it all the time
it's perfected yeah and then when they
come up against that one opponent that
one really good opponent that shuts it
down they can't do anything else even
though the vikings have that passing
game the passing game flows through the
running game and if the running game's
not there the passing game isn't there
because that's when kirk cousins does
his three five seven step drop and it
all falls apart and he can't improvise
it's that thing that separates the best
of the best quarterbacks from the guys
who are just pretty good the ability to
make something happen to whip up on the
fly a batch of chicken salad when the
reality is he collapses like the
proverbial jenga tower when that line
can't hold off the the alignment at a
time when you know the run isn't there
so
you know you can pin the ears back and
you can go after kirk cousins and it's
easier because you know he's not going
to squirt away from you and do something
while he's running laterally that you
know results in a 30-yard gain and he's
not going to take off down the field and
gain 20 yards and he just makes it and
that that's his limitation and that's
the problem he's a great passer
but physically he's limited and i don't
see them doing anything to address that
and i i just i i'm sorry i feel like
they're content to potentially be 10 and
6 11 and 5 9 and 7 get to the playoffs
hope for some sort of a weird alignment
of the planets that allows them to punch
through to the next level and hope that
luck can continue
i i just feel like when they come up
against a truly dominant team
yeah the luck's going to run out well
like it did last year yeah agree well
there's and there's more unproven
commodities on the team this year you
know you know they got to rely on
corners that haven't played like you
talked about a little bit they gotta
rely on justin jefferson who's a rookie
wide receiver and you know they play a
lot of two back one tight end two
receiver sets they're gonna have to rely
on him you know and and mike i think you
bring up a really valid point two things
that you said that really hit me like
yeah you're right they want to run the
ball and do that you know to me a little
bit like the mike zimmer conversation
hey if you want to run the ball
you just you got to be able to throw the
kitchen sink at people when you do run
the ball because if you think you're
just gonna have your four or five
schemes and go oh we're just gonna run
you know we do these well we block them
up well you know hey yeah you know you
might be able to feast on the weak but
to your point when it becomes the really
good defenses those four or five schemes
are just not going to be enough you need
to be
you know more moving parts more multiple
in the run game if you're going to be a
run based team you know allah you know
gary kubiak with you know the shanahan's
look at kyle shanahan look at all the
moving parts you see in their running
game i mean they got guys going every
which way every which direction you know
let alone those four or five schemes we
talk about that gary kubiak has he has
that but you know shanahan has 30
wrinkles off of that that are still
effective run plays that kind of look
like those four or five run schemes to
me that's where they got to open up the
kitchen sink and then mike the biggest
thing to you that you said to me too
you know we talked about the packers
yesterday and we said it was an
underwhelming 13-3 season right you know
when you when when i sat when i sat
there on my computer last night and
looked back at the vikings last year you
know i there's a lot to respect i
certainly don't want to take that away
from them but i do think they had a
schedule that kind of fell right for
them too
you know ten and six yes and you know i
don't know you tell me a marquee win you
guys had during the regular season on
the schedule last year who was the
marquis cowboys sunday night right the
cowboys that was your marquee win you
know to me that kind of shows you like
yeah your team's on the precipice of but
not like big time stop
what stop your team
sorry stop i don't even realize that
turn my hand around and curl down three
of the fingers and you know which three
are going to be curled down if that
happens and it will be we won't make it
to peacock after all um
adam thielen over the weekend was
interviewed by siriusxm nfl radio and he
was asked by bruce murray what the
vikings need to do
to
get to the next level
and what thielen said is they need to
quit talking about getting to the next
level
no no i don't think that's it
i i think they need to get to the point
where the current level is no longer
acceptable
they they need to talk about how
this isn't successful to get balanced in
the divisional round and i thought it
was very telling as thelon gave his
answer he said
we did enough to make the playoffs and
get to the second round which is great
that's a successful season
no it's not
if if you look i i understand that only
one team is going to be successful if
the definition is winning the super bowl
but the thing is the team that
ultimately wins the super bowl typically
is the team that has the overwhelming
obsession to win the super bowl and
there usually are more teams than one
that have that overwhelming obsession
but to me i feel like it's a necessary
ingredient and if you even allow
yourself to think that it's successful
to get balanced in the divisional round
you're missing that thing that is going
to drive you to the super bowl you need
to be tormented that you didn't get
there
in order to have a chance at getting
there does that make any sense at all no
it does make sense you know and honestly
i think that's kind of what he's trying
to say you know he he tried to gift wrap
last year and say it was a successful
season yeah we understand it was a good
year
but you know i think what he's trying to
say too is yeah let's stop all this talk
like just shut up let's go to work and
we need to be edgier and better and more
consistent and whatever it is i think
thielen has a pretty good feel for the
game and what's expected and you know i
i don't know but i don't see it with
your vikings i think you're i think
you're high at 13 with them this year
like high figuratively and literally
calling last season successful is the
equivalent of hanging a banner for being
the afc finalists like the colts did
several years ago it it's not a banner
raising moment there's only one and only
one team gets to do it every year and
everyone who falls short needs to be
tormented by that even though they know
ultimately only one team can do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports